hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Aaron Aaron
is here and you might recognize his face
briefly from dank ass stubs that he does
with Jerry he's never been on the
trailer review show but now he's here
Aaron is here I'm super here I'm in I'm
present I'm in the moment and I found
out he plays games I played a video game
upper two in my day so let's check out
the trailer the dark zone trailer for
the division Tom Clancy's Tom Clancy's
the division he does to war what John
Grisham does two trials he's kind of
like hey just get guns it's crazy how
tom clancy's games have become pretty
popular yes his movies got pretty big
it's insane that like Tom Clancy is up
there with FIFA as far as like
franchises that I've connected the video
game world mm-hmm it's like what's this
Pierce people like what's this you're
Tom Clancy gonna me make it ain't
content get rid of your children we were
always told it might come to this
so water bottles in that one day
everything we ever knew could end snow
day
[Music]
it was a weaponized virus
or one-by-one we began to fall people
started tearing each other apart until
society as we knew it collapsed
it was a signal that the normal lives we
led we're gone
Jr had debated as a last resort
we are the division you don't know how
many of us there are or what it will
take to save what remains
but there was one thing we do
there cannot be any hope for tomorrow
before we don't fight for today
available March 8th 2016 [ __ ] Yankees
getting delayed next 8 2016 huh it was
originally supposed to be coming out in
2014 I think so the graphics yes on
board for the graphics there are several
graphic there are some pro graphics
these are the textures and mommy
yes in this game and some animations and
shadows
it all works it looks good yeah it looks
really good it's it's realistic that the
legs of the little deployable tripod
mounted turret kind of jitter with
recoil but still looks kind of cute and
silly what I really like from this
trailer is the tone in the world
something that I would like to sort of
be a part of in terms of a video game
experience yeah it'd be cool to play as
like oh when society has fallen the
people to really help get it in orders
the division yeah and I remember like I
am Alive before I kind of got stripped
down to just like in Xbox Live Arcade
title a few years back like when when
the first trailers were coming up for I
am Alive you're in that savage not
post-apocalyptic but post societal
collapse urban world this trailer you
don't really feel who the enemy is it
just kind of I see dudes and backpacks
shooting dudes that are vaguely in
orange yeah I mean to me I guess because
they said it was a virus and the virus
made the whole like the United States
just collapse in a few days yeah so it
seems like these people are just trying
to keep society or like they're the
they're the law when I saw a lot it was
like a bunch of criminals are they
supposed to be like jailbreakers war
that's what it looks like right yeah it
does look like that and this is just a
lot of speculation but maybe those guys
in jumpsuits are like people that broken
out of like a quarantine zone and
they're like no don't hold me against my
will I don't care that I'm spreading
your horrible illness that'd be a cool
thing to include yeah yeah I got that
last of us 5 the last of us had that
kind of zombie feel because the the
enemies in the last of us are pseudo
inhuman it's just the trailer doesn't
feel like there's enough to really go
off of I don't get a super strong vibe
for what this game is about outside of
shooting guys yeah yeah it would be nice
to know like we've liked
are they going after the people
who like created this virus yeah I would
like to know something like that I don't
quite get where the division between
friend and enemy is drawn interesting
yeah well worded my friend Jim it's a
because the name of the game was in the
sentence I said that happened that's
what they call it clever comedy right
there anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the real rejects if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects Aaron you can catch this podcast
with Jerry on dank ass stuffs here on
the real rejects Channel and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter and vine cuz if we get into
followers we can get product placement
people meaning more money for me
no benefit for you maybe they'll get
like a higher production value for the
content hmm
so it's like an indirect benefit I
wouldn't put any money towards that what
would you spend product placement money
on I don't like that face it strap-ons
you have a penis it's not be enough to
satisfy the woman my girl [ __ ] needs
big